about two years ago a rupture happened
in liverpool's underworld police
infiltrated an encrypted messaging
service called encroa chat used
internationally by criminals operation
venetic was launched
operation phonetic has really opened up
law enforcement national crime agency
and partners eyes to what organized
criminal networks and how they operate
uh within the uk uh it identified how
they managed to speak to each other in a
clandestine way and also how they
managed to do their various deals not
just within the uk but internationally
as well
in the uk around three quarters of the
messages about gun crime had links to
liverpool and the north west
[Applause]
this along with merseyside police's
focus on dismantling county lines drug
networks has led to hundreds of arrests
in the city
that's left a gap and that's going to be
backfilled with younger people from the
estates who then be coming up coming up
the ranks and they have to do something
to gain significance within that group
and all disputes are settled with either
knives or guns
organized criminals may supply the
weapons but turf wars are disorganized
the majority of shootings in the uk are
committed by street gangs and the
victims generally known to the police
but the rivalries are as chaotic as they
are brutal however one expert in
organized gang crime says even hardened
criminals won't tolerate the callous
killing of nine-year-old olivia i have
every confidence that someone
in the liverpool area
who knows
who has done this
will come forward because it is my view
that even the most senior and organized
criminals will find this as abort
as we do
liverpool is famous for many positive
things but though we are far from
understanding the motives this appalling
crime has once again exposed a dreadful
underbelly in this community
jason farrell sky news liverpool